[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON YEE: Yeah, the party
last night was awesome.
So thanks to Google for that.
They had Gwen Stefani there.
And I realized, as
I was at the party,
that Gwen Stefani is
probably a tech worker.
And I'm convinced of this
because her last song,
"Hollaback Girl"--
I'm convinced that that
song is about being on call,
because she ain't
no hollaback girl.
So she doesn't
want to be on call.
And she says this [MUTED]
bananas, B-A-N-A-N-A-S.
And I think that explains
pretty much all of our systems
that we build, which is why
I want to talk about Chaos.
Things are bananas.
Oftentimes, when
I'm building stuff,
my reaction is either,
oh, my God, that worked!
Right?
Because it's just, like, I can't
believe this stuff actually
works.
Or it's, like, oh,
my God, that worked?
You have a problem,
your system goes down,
and you're, like,
how the hell did
this work in the first place?
This shouldn't even
be functioning.
So Chaos is about learning
about our systems.
So more fun quotes--
I love this quote
from Barack Obama
that says "You can't let
your failures define you.
You have to let your
failures teach you."
You have to learn from them.
Which is what Chaos is
really about, right?
Our systems break all the time.
There's a researcher on
safety named David Woods.
He gets mentioned in a lot
dev ops sort of circles.
And he has this quote
that our systems are
in a constant state of failure.
Failure isn't binary.
It's just a spectrum.
And so if we understand
that, that we're failing,
and that's OK, right?
Because we can learn from it.
Now Barack Obama talked
about a whole lot of things.
He talked a lot about hope.
Unfortunately, that's
maybe not a good thing.
So I love this quote about hope.
Corey Bertram is the VP
of Infrastructure and SRE
at Datadog.
And he likes to say this,
that hope is not a strategy.
We can't hope that our
systems will stay up.
We can't hope that our software
will deploy without any bugs.
How many people deployed
sometime this week?
Deployed some code,
deployed infrastructure,
spun something up?
That's most of us.
How many people
deployed bad code?
You had a bug, or you deployed
infrastructure and it broke?
And that's pretty much
the same amount of hands.
If you didn't,
then I don't know--
good job on you?
Or maybe you missed something.
And you should be
really worried.
So the other thing
about Corey, though--
and the reason that
Corey says this
is that Corey came from Netflix.
So he was part of the team
that started implementing
a lot of chaos around things.
And so the story of this is that
Netflix was moving from on prem
to the cloud.
And as they were doing so,
they realized a lot of things
about the cloud.
They realized that cloud
isn't about resiliency.
Even though Google
provides these great SLAs
and they're up most of the time,
just like us, there are issues.
And they work to resolve them.
But the great thing
about Google Cloud
is that you can spin up
new resources all the time.
So you have this ability to
constantly have more resources.
And that means that rather
than avoiding failure,
you can embrace failure, you
can start planning for failure
and doing things like
rollovers, or auto scaling,
and things like that.
So they had a lot
of these lessons.
The number one lesson that
I like from this blog post
that they posted was that
the best way to avoid failure
is to constantly fail, to
constantly try to fail.
Do those painful things.
And then learn from them.
And this led them to creating
a thing called Chaos Monkeys.
Who here has heard
of Chaos Monkey?
Yeah.
I think we all
have at this point.
Who here has heard that
it's this program that
randomly deletes your
servers, takes things down?
Yeah.
I mean, that was
the point, right?
Unfortunately, I think a lot
of us have believed this.
And if you go back and
read the blog post,
that's sort of a myth.
And I'll dive into
that in a bit.
So who am I?
I don't come from Netflix.
I'm Jason.
I work at Datadog.
I'm a technical evangelist,
which is a really fun job.
It means I get to come and
talk to people like you.
I get to help our customers.
I get to learn stuff, and
then teach people, as well.
A bunch of things about me--
I do actually have
a hat like that.
I play a lot of Pokemon Go.
If you see me wandering
around later, I'm not lost.
A little bit about Datadog.
Datadog is a SaaS-based
monitoring platform.
So we work with Google.
We work with your on prem.
If you're doing multi-cloud,
we work with all
the major cloud providers.
But we ingest all of your
metrics, your traces,
distributed traces.
We collect your logs,
help you do log analytics.
And we launched a new
synthetics product.
So essentially, we try to get
you all the observability tools
to let you know what's
going on in your systems,
let you know where you can find
those issues when something
does happen.
And this is important
when it comes to Chaos.
So back to it to Netflix and
talking about Chaos, right?
If you actually go back to
their blog post, it says this.
That by running Chaos Monkey--
not randomly, not
at any given time,
but in the middle
of a business day
in a carefully monitored
environment with engineers
standing by--
well, then we can
address those problems
and learn the
lessons that we need
to learn about the
weaknesses in our systems,
about how to build the
automatic recovery mechanisms--
which is one thing, as
mentioned, that the cloud now
enables us to do.
And so by doing all of this,
then maybe at 3 AM on a Sunday,
on those random times, then
we won't even notice, right?
We can build all these things.
So lesson one from this
talk, if you come out of here
and you're, like,
yeah, I'm going
to go do some Chaos stuff.
And you're doing it in
the middle of the night.
And you're not telling
your colleagues.
And you're waking them up
in the middle of the night,
then you're a jerk.
And my number one lesson
is don't be a jerk.
We'll talk about
how to plan these.
We'll have talked
about how to run these
so that you're actually learning
and being a good colleague.
So at Datadog, we
start with Game Days.
And the main difference
between Game Days and Chaos
is that Game Days are very
much a manual process.
And that's where you
want to start, right?
You don't want to just
jump into automation
that you don't understand.
So just like any game at
Datadog, there are rules.
I was in Italy.
So this is the
Italian soccer team.
And I was pointing out to
them that the rules are there
to make the game fun.
If you were playing
a soccer game,
and there were no
rules, well, then
I can come up and punch you
in the face and take the ball
and run, throw it in the goal.
And you'd be like,
hey, that's not soccer.
That sounds like rugby.
It's only fun if there are
rules that we all agree upon.
And so the rules make
things a little less scary.
They let us know what to expect.
So the rules of the Game Day
are just like a soccer match.
It lasts 90 minutes.
We want to time box this.
We don't want it to go on for
a full day, because then we
lose productivity.
We don't want things
to just drag on and on,
so we keep things
nice and short.
Within that 90 minutes, we
spend 30 minutes for planning.
Again, we want to
keep this short.
Nobody wants to spend half
a day or a day planning what
they're going to do--
so 30 minutes, nice short
period, doesn't take too long.
Then we spend 50
minutes playing.
This is the actual fun part.
This is where we get
to test our systems.
This is where we get to break
things and see what happens.
And then again, 10 minutes at
the end just for reporting.
And we don't want
this to be too long.
Again, if it's too
long for reporting,
nobody wants to do it, right?
That's the boring
part of things.
So the 10 minutes, nice
and short, and I'll
dive into to how
this works in a bit.
But let's talk about the team.
Every game has teams.
So our teams are nice and small.
We don't want to take
up everybody's time,
because again, we
lose productivity.
So the team ends up being
two, usually two people.
The first is a
subject matter expert.
And that's going to
be the developer who
built the service, who
knows the most about it.
It might be the ops
engineer who architected
this particular
service's infrastructure.
Whoever knows the
most about it, that's
the person that's going to be
the main player on this team.
The next person is going to
be someone from the SRE team.
So they're going to partner up.
Because the SREs are
really those experts
on how to keep your
systems running,
how to keep them reliable,
what the best practices are.
So now we can partner
up with the person who's
building things, the person
who essentially helps
ensure that they stay running.
It's a good team.
Sometimes, though, we
add a third player.
And that third player is
going to be a junior engineer
or a junior developer.
And more often than not, I like
when we have a third player.
Because that third player, this
junior engineer, is the person
that knows just a little
bit about that service,
or just a little bit
about that infrastructure.
So when you take something down
and you see some weird symptoms
around that, this
is the person that
has no idea why that happened.
They're the person that asks
those questions, because there
are no stupid questions.
But they ask those
questions about why did that
happen, right?
What's going on?
Wait.
Why did we do that in the code?
Why did we build that this way?
And for most of us
that have been around,
well, you're like, well,
of course, oh, yeah.
That's not really
the logical way.
We did it because there
is this other constraint.
So that's the great
thing about it.
The other nice thing is,
as a more senior engineer
or developer, you get
to mentor that person.
Right?
Now they're seeing
the reasons that you
built that service or that
system in a particular way.
They understand
now when you say,
oh, yeah, I did that weird
thing because this constraint.
Now, as a junior engineer,
when they come up
with strange
constraints or things
that they're not
familiar with, now they
have some reference
of, like, oh, here's
a creative way that you did it.
So let's talk about
those times, though.
30 minutes spent planning-- what
do we do for that 30 minutes?
Well, number one, we
have to schedule this.
We want to ensure that
we have enough time
to do this 90 minutes.
Do not start this at
4:00 PM on a Friday.
Because if it runs long,
if something happens,
it's eating into your weekend.
So plan it.
Schedule it for at
least those 90 minutes.
But maybe add a
little bit of time
in case you need
that extra time.
Then, simply, you
pick your tests.
You start easy.
Figure out what
you're going to do.
you want to break,
how you want to break it.
It's not too hard.
Write down what you
expect to happen
when you do break things.
So think of it as a
scientific experiment.
What's your hypothesis?
If I take down the data store,
what's my service going to do?
What sort of alerting
should I receive?
Your hypothesis
does not have to be,
and probably shouldn't
be every single time,
that your service survives.
We'll talk about some of
the tests that we run.
But it's really not
logical to assume
that you can build
services that,
if you cut off all their
critical dependencies,
if you drop the network,
that they're just
going to keep going hunky dory.
Everything's fine, right?
So write down what
you expect to happen.
Also write down
what your plan is.
What's your fallback plan if
everything goes wrong, if you
have a cascading failure?
Let's say you start
off in staging.
And you're, like, cool.
I've got these
tests, no problem.
I don't expect things to fail.
So you don't write up a plan.
And suddenly you take
down all of staging.
Your entire
organization is down.
Nobody can test the code.
No one can work.
Well, that's a bad problem.
So whatever you do
write down your Plan B.
What are you going to
do if things go wrong?
And then finally,
most importantly,
share the document.
Not just to your team, not
just to the two people playing,
that other SRE that's with
you, or if you're the SRE,
not just to the engineer
or the junior engineer.
Send it as wide as
you can, at least
to your entire engineering
organization, all
of your developers, all
of your ops engineers.
But even consider
more broadly, right?
If you're starting to do
game days in production,
send it company wide.
Right?
Think about your account
managers or your sales reps.
If they're out there talking to
a customer and the customer--
you know, your Chaos engineering
plan kind of fell apart
and starts to impact latency
on your production systems,
and your customers
start complaining,
they're going to
not complain to you.
They're going to
complain to their account
reps or the salespeople.
So it's good to share
this information
as broadly as possible, because
it may impact other people.
And it's good for them to know.
So that's the 30 minutes,
nice short planning, not too
much involved.
So what happens during?
Well, during, when we
actually run the game days,
we do start off in staging.
You want to start off
in a safe environment.
And then once it passes
there, we'll promote that
and we'll try it in production,
during off peak hours.
And then we'll move
that to prime time.
We'll run it in production in
heavy times of actual customer
traffic.
So when we start
the game day, when
we start the actual playing,
you want to announce that.
And you want to announce that
within your group chat tool,
whatever you're
using, Hipchat, Slack,
whatever sort of chat
ops tool you're using.
Because it's a way to get
things broadly, right?
If I just come into the
room and say, hey everyone,
I'm doing this.
Well, you know, Bob might
be out getting coffee.
He has no idea
that that happened.
So we want to
announce it in a tool
that everybody has access to and
in a tool that records things.
Because we want to maintain
our discussions there.
Because if it's me and an
SRE, and we're teaming up,
and we take down a system.
And I'm trying to type up notes.
And things are going on.
Well, what did I say
five minutes ago?
I was talking about this
thing that I observed,
and then you saw
this other thing.
If it's all in Slack,
if it's all in Hipchat
or whatever you're using, now
I have a complete dialogue
of everything that was said.
When it comes to
taking notes later,
then I can just post
a link and say here's
what we saw here's
what we're discussing.
Keep things nice and easy.
We also want to
monitor for outages.
And we do this in two ways.
Obviously, at Datadog,
we're a monitoring company.
So we have tons of dashboards.
You want to keep
whatever monitoring
tool you've got open, be
monitoring your systems.
But also, we have an outage
channel within Slack.
So we want to keep
aware of that.
Because if anyone
declares an actual outage,
that's a cue for us to
stop what we're doing.
We don't want to add
our Game Day or Chaos
into their actual real
chaos while they're
trying to debug their systems
or bring systems back online.
So you want to monitor for that.
And then, finally, you play.
You break your systems.
You run your tests.
You take your notes.
You explore your systems,
see what they do.
For the after, again, we want
to keep this nice and short.
Because this is the boring part.
This is not the fun
part of playing.
But the great thing
is you've taken notes.
You have that
dialogue within Slack.
So you just paste
the link to that.
You create cards and tickets.
Whatever tracking
system you're using,
whether that's Jira or
Trello, whatever you've got,
you write those down.
The things that you
saw, like, oh, yeah,
when we broke this thing
our monitor didn't go off
the way we thought it did.
Or I got an alert, but it had
useless information in it.
So you just create the
tickets right there.
Make sure that those get done.
You write your summary
and the key lessons.
And the summary is
essentially your notes.
Again, you don't have to
spend a whole lot of time,
you shouldn't spend a whole
lot of time with this.
Copy your notes in there.
Copy the link to Slack.
Write up some of the
things that you observed,
those key lessons, those
key points that you
want people to take away.
And then you email that
out to all of engineering,
at least, at a
very minimum, maybe
to your entire organization.
Because again, the
whole point about this
is learning from these failures.
So spreading that
information as far as we can
becomes beneficial.
And finally, the most important
part is you celebrate.
At Datadog, we love to celebrate
anything and everything.
Any possibility to celebrate,
we do, including Game Days.
If the Game Day goes
great, and you're, like,
we expected that our system
would be completely resilient.
We hammered it with traffic.
We essentially DDoSed
ourself and it auto
scaled up and handled
all that perfectly,
or our [INAUDIBLE]
actually blocked that,
because that's what we were
expecting-- like, great.
You won.
You built a resilient system.
Congrats.
You celebrate that.
But similarly, if I roll
out my Chaos experiment,
and there is a
cascading failure,
and I take down all of staging,
and the entire engineering
department's mad at me because
everyone has to stop work,
well, I fix that.
But then I celebrate.
Right?
Because I just learned
something that's
really important
about our systems.
I learned where that
critical fault was.
And now we're on the
road to fixing that.
So you want to celebrate
everything when you do these.
So let's talk about
the tests that we run.
We have five different
levels, or six,
because we number with zero.
But the first is to
terminate the service.
If I turn off this service
and I just restart it,
does it actually restart?
Does it restart without
any human intervention?
If I have to restart my server
and then log in and enter
some credentials because I'm not
using a secrets manager, well,
that's a bad thing.
If I restart my application,
and because I did that,
because it was down, my router
isn't actually sending traffic
to that, well, great.
If your service is up,
but not receiving traffic,
that's a bad thing.
So really simple--
terminate your service.
The other thing we
do at this level
is block access to one
critical dependency.
So whatever that is, if it's
you've got a build system
and it needs to load
libraries or other components,
block that.
What happens with
your build system?
If it's a service that has
a persistent data store,
what happens if you block
access to that data store?
Again, it doesn't
have to survive.
If I have a user log in
service and I block access
to that data store and
people can't log in,
well, that's not great.
But at least that's what
I should expect, right?
And if that's what
I expect and that's
the way that the
service operates,
well, then that's a good thing.
From there, we level up.
We block access to
all the dependencies.
And again, we want to ensure
that it acts the way we expect
it to, not that it survives.
If it survives, that's amazing.
But we want to ensure that
it expects the way we do.
So we want to verify that errors
are reported, right, that we
have proper monitoring on that.
If we block all
those dependencies,
we should at least get
some sort of alert.
And that automated alert
should go to my team.
It should have links
to my dashboards.
It should have links back to
some sort of documentation
with a runbook that
says, if this happens,
here's what you look at.
Here's what you try
to do to resolve that.
The next level up is we
terminate the entire host.
So we take down that
node or that VM.
And we see if it fails
over to another one.
Hopefully, it does.
We verify that that traffic gets
redirected to that new host.
Because we don't want to
have to manually do that.
This also helps us guarantee
that hosts are replicated
across availability zones and
that similarly, their data
stores are replicated, as well.
Level 3 is that we
degrade the environment.
So we're starting to get a
little more complex here.
But we do things like
slow down the network.
Start dropping packets,
introduce jitter.
We want to verify here
that we can survive this,
or that at least, if
that data is coming in
and it's incomplete because
we've missed packets,
that our systems can
now start to maybe retry
those, or at least
identify that it's
gotten malformed information.
We also want to verify that
we have what I call LETS.
So Google, a while
back, their SRE team
wrote the Google SRE handbook.
It's published by O'Reilly.
And they have this thing
called the four golden signals.
Which-- it's a high,
nice, lofty name.
I never remember what it is.
So I reorganized
it and said LETS.
LETS is a nice acronym for
latency, errors, traffic,
and saturation.
Latency-- are we seeing
increases in latency?
Do we have proper
monitoring for that?
Errors-- are we monitoring what
sort of errors we're receiving?
What's the error rate?
Traffic-- are we seeing more
traffic or less traffic?
And we want to monitor
that in both ways.
If I'm seeing more traffic,
well, that could be good.
It could mean that
whatever we tried,
users are actually
engaging more,
so we're seeing higher traffic.
Or it could be
bad, that something
that we rolled out,
something that we're testing
is less than optimal.
And now we're issuing more
requests against the server.
Similarly, saturation-- do
we have enough resources,
whether that's
computes, I/O, network.
The great thing
about this, though,
is once you pass this
level, once you're
able to survive a
degraded environment,
once you're sure that we have
complete monitoring on that,
that we've got those
metrics, that we've
traced this application,
that we've got proper logs--
this is the time when you can
actually hand off to the SRE.
So up until this
point, at Datadog,
if you write a service,
you write that service,
you're responsible for it.
Which means that
you're on call for it.
You have to run what you write.
But at this point,
because we know
we have full monitoring
on this, we've
tested that things react the
way we think they should.
We've got proper alerts that
have runbooks that tell people,
even if they don't know
very much about the service,
it tells them exactly
what they should
do in case of an incident.
Well, that means it's
ready to go to an SRE.
So now that SRE can actually
start to take over some of your
on call responsibilities.
Which-- this is a great,
great level to get to, right?
It means no more
constant on call.
You have somebody
to back you up.
So you can sleep
better at night.
Level 4 is where we
spike the traffic.
So we essentially try to
DDoS our own services.
What happens when I
receive a ton of traffic?
Do I have auto
scaling turned on?
Is my service setup
to run asynchronously?
Can I pass those jobs off
and queue them and then
run them at a later time?
And then Level 5 is mass
destruction, nuclear outage?
What happens if we
just nuke Google Cloud?
Can I fail over to an on prem?
Can I fail over to
another cloud provider?
I do have to caveat with
saying that, at Datadog, we're
multi-cloud.
But not all of our services
are at this level yet.
This is the dream.
This is where we're
pushing towards.
And actually, that Google
announcement, Anthos,
that's pretty cool, right?
You can start to do multi-cloud.
And they're making it easier.
So I've talked about
a lot of stuff.
I know it's early, and
I've seen that some of you
are starting to nod off.
So who wants to
run an experiment?
Yeah.
All right.
So let's switch over
and run an experiment.
I'm going to keep this nice
and easy, because it is early.
But let's start off
with that planning.
This planning, it would
be normally 30 minutes.
But because we're
in this session
and I have 25 minutes
left, we can't actually
spend that amount of time.
But scheduling it-- congrats,
we're doing it right now.
I'm letting you know right now.
We're going to choose a test.
So I've got a WordPress site,
because I think everybody
understands WordPress.
It's a nice, simple,
easy thing to do.
Let's kill MySQL.
What happens if WordPress
has no data store?
And let's try a few ways.
So I've got it
running in Kubernetes.
So I'm going to say that the way
we're going to kill this is we
can kill the pod.
We can kill the deployment.
And then actually, I was
wondering last night.
I've never actually done this.
But what if I log into
my pod and just kill -9
the actual service?
So what do we expect to happen?
Shout it out.
If you have a WordPress
site and MySQL goes down,
what do you think's
going to happen?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JASON YEE: WordPress is going
to get even slower, nice.
High latency on WordPress--
someone said 500 error.
Anything else?
What can we expect
if I take WordPress--
MySQL down.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JASON YEE: MySQL errors?
All right.
What about alerting?
I should receive some
sort of alerts, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JASON YEE: Cool.
Those are some good things.
What are we going to do if
things go horribly wrong?
Well, we're going to walk away.
It's early.
So I'm probably not going to
go to a bar and get a beer.
But if things go horribly
wrong, and for some reason
this cascades and takes down
the Google Cloud network, then
yeah, I'm definitely walking
away, and maybe running away.
But maybe we can go get
some coffee and hang out.
Cool.
That's it for planning,
nice and easy, right?
And then I share this.
So this is actually
available online.
I've got the URL.
And that'll be in
the slides later.
Cool.
So just to show you, I do
have this WordPress site
that's here.
It looks like it's
operating pretty good.
And I'm going to switch over
I've got WordPress running
in just Minikube on my
computer here because I didn't
want to tempt the demo gods.
But we can see that, yes, I
still have some pods running.
So we go back to our document.
And I said what
are we going to do?
Well, let's kill the pod.
So if I do let's delete pod.
And I'm going to
take down MySQL here.
Cool, it says it's deleted.
I can come back here, I see
an error, and then it's back.
Cool.
That's pretty much
what we expected.
Kubernetes is nice
and fast at that.
So if I just go
back up there, we
can see that, yes, it restarted.
It was pulling up
everything just fine here.
It's got still got my image.
So my persistent
volume claim worked.
So things that we saw--
we can just say that
we killed the pod.
And it responds as expected.
Cool.
Super easy, right?
So let's try-- what if we
delete that deployment?
Cool.
So now if I do that, we should
see that my pod is terminating.
It is-- come back here.
We see that ugly error
establishing database.
So we'll make a note of that.
WordPress is essentially
nonresponsive,
nonresponsive with an error.
And then I should get alerts.
So let's see.
Did I actually get an alert?
Let's go to my monitors.
I do have an alert here
that MySQL was killed.
I want to check in my email.
If I refresh here, I did
get an alert on my email.
And it's got some
information here,
which might be hard for
you to read in the back.
It says MySQL is killed.
If this was not intentional,
please verify the Kubernetes
deployment.
Number one, check the
Kubernetes dashboard.
So I can click on that.
It takes me to Datadog.
It loads up my dashboard here.
I can take a look at this.
I see that pods desired,
pods available, five.
So those match,
desired and ready.
So overall, it looks like things
are working quite nicely still
on Kubernetes, which is
what we would expect.
Then it says check out our team
documentation, which I don't
have any example documentation.
But that's probably a
good thing for us to do.
And then it says
to restart MySQL.
Ensure you have the
latest YAML files.
And then run this command.
So let's verify that our
instructions in our alert
is actually what we expect.
All right?
So I reapply that.
It looks like those
are unchanged.
And then it's got
my deployment there.
So it's recreated that.
And if I get my pods,
it's back up and running.
So does this actually run here?
Cool.
WordPress is back, right,
exactly as we expect.
So we killed that.
We should say that
we received alerts.
It had some steps that worked.
So we can fill this out
a little bit more later.
But we're just
taking notes here.
Anything that we didn't
expect-- no, not yet.
So we had one more thing
that we wanted to try
and that was up here.
Let's log into the pod
and kill -9 the service
and see what happens.
So I've got my pod that's
back up and running.
That bin bash.
Cool.
Oh, that's fun.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JASON YEE: Oh, yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
No, oh.
So this is a fun
thing, good to know,
that we are running, maybe,
I think this is Alpine.
Which means that
they removed that.
Yeah.
All right.
So I'm not going to dive
down that rabbit hole.
But that's a good thing.
And that's actually something
that we can note here, right?
We were actually running--
we're running in a
minimal container
that doesn't have ps, right?
The cool thing about that,
though, is we probably,
in this case-- if we're
running this in production,
we want some other tools.
So things that we should
change or fix now,
as we're taking notes, is we
should set up some dev tools.
So we can ps on containers.
Cool.
We just learned something.
And actually, I
hadn't planned this.
I was just randomly
thinking what would happen
if I did that this morning.
Cool.
So experiment has been run.
Again, super easy,
we learned some stuff
about what we're running.
And then we've got
the lessons learned.
So again, this is
the super short part.
It should just be 10 minutes.
We make Jira tickets.
So this is our Jira ticket.
So we go into
Jira, we make that.
We write a summary of things we
saw, things we didn't expect,
which essentially is
copy pasting this.
Right?
And then we share this.
So we're going to
email this out.
And then finally we celebrate.
[APPLAUSE]
So yeah, we ran an experiment.
It worked.
We learned some stuff.
Cool.
So I'm going to
update this Gist.
And it's now saved, so you
guys have access to it.
So if we go back to the
slides, just to review--
if I had to boil this
down to three points,
there's all this advice on
how you should run things.
But at the end of the day,
it comes down to this.
It's sharing.
Share what you do.
When you're planning
things out, you're
sharing that as broadly in
your organization as you can.
And when you're actually running
things, you're sharing that.
You're letting people
know that you're running.
And then finally, you're
sharing what you learned
across your organizations.
Number two, to sum
this up, is to plan.
Simply just come up
with those experiments.
Plan those out.
Plan what's going to happen
if things go horribly wrong.
And then finally, have fun.
We're learning about things.
We just learned that
we didn't have ps.
We don't have the proper admin
tools within our containers.
So we need to plan for that.
Have fun.
Celebrate.
We just learned that.
So I wish I could
take you all out
and buy you a celebratory beer.
But it's also
super early, so you
can celebrate in your own way.
A few other resources--
though, again,
I advise you to
keep things simple--
systemctl, kill, kill
-9 your services.
You don't need super complex,
fancy tools for this.
Keep things simple when
you're testing them.
A few other things
that we do use, though,
as we start to level
up, I mentioned
that you want to simulate
bad network conditions.
So that's what
Comcast is there for.
It's a nice tool.
It is hilarious.
I shouldn't say disparaging
things about Comcast.
But I think we've all
experienced their ISP services.
Vegeta is a nice one.
If you've ever used
Apache Bench, which
comes with the
Apache web server,
Apache Bench essentially
allows you to simulate traffic.
Vegeta is like Apache
Bench on steroids.
So it's written in Go.
You can essentially
DDoS yourself.
But it's also got some great
tools where, when you do that,
it'll start saving up some data.
And you can type that
back into Vegeta.
And it'll generate
drafts for you
so you can actually have
nice summaries of what
you've been doing.
A few other things--
Gremlin, I know, they are
sponsoring downstairs.
But Gremlin is
Chaos as a service.
They rolled out a
free service, which
allows you to essentially
do node killing,
or service killing, and then
also CPU tests, as well.
So those are available freely.
They integrate with Datadog,
so it's really cool.
If you do use Datadog, you
can launch those directly
from your dashboards.
It lets you know when
the test was running.
It allows you to
monitor your metrics
through the course of the test.
And then, finally,
Chaos Toolkit,
another great resource--
they have a bunch
of information on
how to run Chaos
experiments, a bunch of tools
that you can actually use,
as well.
So with that said,
open the questions.
So if you think of anything
afterward, you leave here,
and you're like, oh,
I wish I knew more
about this, feel
free to email me,
or that's my Twitter handle.
You can tweet at me, and
I'll answer those questions,
as well.
And then these slides
are available online.
And the documents of the
experiment that we just ran--
those are available
in the Gist, as well.
[MUSIC PLAYING]